hola de nuevo en este vídeo planeo
concluir el problema de la vez pasada
que nos pedía encontrar la distancia
desde el barco que se salió de curso y
el punto b entonces bien estamos
tratando de simplificar esta ecuación
que se ve un poco fea y como es un vídeo
nuevo voy a cambiar de color porque no
entonces
esta expresión de aquí lo que voy a
hacer es juntar esta escena al cuadrado
con este coseno al cuadrado entonces
podría factorizar el 25 que está al
frente de ambos y escribir esto como 25
por el seno al cuadrado de 15 grados
más el coseno al cuadrado de 15 grados
recuerden factor hice el 25 y todo eso
más 100
100 - cien veces el coseno de 15 grados
ahora bien cuánto vale el seno al
cuadrado de 15 grados más ricos en al
cuadrado 15 grados pues es identidad es
básica es de las primeras que aprendimos
la identidad pitagórica y nos dice que
esto en realidad vale 1 toda esta suma
vale 1 así que esto lo podría escribir
como 25 más 100
menos 100 veces el coseno de 15 grados
y solo para que no se les olvide esto es
d al cuadrado de es la distancia entre
el barco y el punto b ok entonces esto
sería lo mismo que 25 + 100 sería 125
menos 100 por el coseno de 15 grados y
bueno supongamos que de repente se
aparece un hada y boom nos da el coseno
de 15 grados nos dice el cosa no 15
grados vale 0.96 593 entonces si lo
multiplicó por 100 el punto decimal se
recorre dos espacios y se convierte esto
en 125 menos 96.500 93
ahora bien cuánto es esto cuánto vale
esta diferencia
pues supongamos que al hada que nos dio
el coseno de 15 grados se le cayó a su
calculadora y nosotros la recogimos y
aquí está la calculadora de helada así
que bien cuánto vale 125 menos 90 y 625
- perdón menos 96.500 93
pues la calculadora nos dice que es
28.400 728 punto 407 ahora esto es lo
que vale
d al cuadrado entonces cuánto vale de
cuánto vale de vamos a hacerlo con rojo
de va a valer la raíz cuadrada de esto
de vale la raíz cuadrada de 28.400 7
y eso debe ser como 5 punto algo pero
vamos a consultar la calculadora mágica
del hada
sacamos raíz y si 5.32 9
así que de vale 5.32 9 y esa es la
distancia en kilómetros a la cual está
el barco del punto b
quizás el el capitán del barco también
tendría que determinar cuál tiene que
ser su curso a seguir por todo es la
corriente y todo lo demás pero no nos
pregunto eso así que vamos a dejar este
problema aquí espero que lo hayan
entendido si no lo entendieron pues les
recomiendo que chequen los vídeos acerca
de trigonometría y le echen una repasada
a las dos partes de este problema hasta
la próxima